lexie les régionales est-ce que
clairement c'est un enjeu majeur pour la
république en marche
oui un enjeu majeur du moins un enjeu
important dans le dispositif de pré
campagne pour 2022 on sait que la
république en marche est un parti qui a
eu du mal à s'en créer un dans les
régions dans les villes dans les
territoires les municipales ont été
difficiles pour ce parti qui avait fait
2 5% qui a été obligé toujours de faire
des listes finalement d'agrégation ou de
faire la stratégie du coucou c'est à
dire de prendre un parti et de se mettre
au sein du parti
aujourd'hui on voit la même mécanique à
l'oeuvre au sein des régionales avec de
nombreux ministres qui sont candidats
également parce qu'il s'agit de faire de
la communication et on choisit des
ministres médiatique comme eric dupond
moretti
gabriel attal marlène schiappa c'est des
ministres que les gens connaissent même
ceux qui ne s'intéressent pas vraiment à
la politique parce que finalement
personne ne sait qui sont aujourd'hui
les cadres du mouvement de la république
en marche il a peut-être un peu
stanislas guérini mais c'est extrêmement
compliqué si on ne s'intéresse pas à la
politique donc il s'agit de faire une
campagne de communication autour
bien sûr de la défense du bilan d'
emmanuel macron avant que lui-même le
fasse lors de son tour de france cet été
et d'assurer non pas une
un effacement du champ politique mais
d'encre et quelques personnes de la
république en marche pour le long terme
au sein des régions au sein des villes
ça a été raté donc peut-être que les
régions vont permettre à ce parti de
durer si non il va s'évaporer dès 2022
même pour le renouvellement du mandat
des modèles macron il ne comptera pas
sur ce parti il va faire un dépassement
une nouvelle majorité présidentielle
avec par exemple le groupe qui vient
nouvellement d'être créée par christian
estrosi sans doute avec le groupe de
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe et d'autres qui vont petit à
petit rejoindre est malade mâcon sur
cette nouvelle plateforme pour pousser
la raim qui est devenu finalement un
repoussoir plutôt que une étiquette
vendeuse notamment marketing politique
donc clairement les régionales sont un
enjeu dans la première marche de ce
début de campagne des présidentielles
merci alexis poulamon merci d'avoir été
avec nous